PAUL LI: Hi.
Good morning, everyone.
Thank you all for coming.
My name is Paul Li.
I'm a science administrator
at the Gladstone Institutes
and a faculty member in
the cognitive sciences
at UC Berkeley.
Today we're going to kick off
our new initiative coming out
from the Gladstone Institutes
called Open Classroom
Talks, where we send our
scientists outside to Bay Area
communities, such
as Google, to share
their interdisciplinary
research.
So to start off our
Open Classroom Talks,
I'd like to introduce
you to our guest speaker
for today, Dr.
Katie Pollard, who
is a senior investigator
at the Gladstone Institutes
and a professor
in human genetics
and biostatistics at UCSF.
She received her Ph.D. from UC
Berkeley, where she developed
computationally intensive
statistical methods
for analysis of microarray
data with applications
in cancer biology.
For her post-doctoral
work, also at Berkeley,
she developed bioconductor
open-source software packages
for clustering and multiple
hypothesis testing.
Katie was also part of the
chimpanzee sequencing analysis
consortium that published a
sequence of the chimp genome,
and she used the
sequence to identify
the fastest-evolving
regions in the human genome.
In 2005, she joined the faculty
at the UC Davis Genome Center
and the Department of
Statistics before moving to UCSF
in fall 2008.
So without further
ado, please join me
in welcoming Dr. Katie
Pollard, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
KATHERINE POLLARD: Hi everybody.
It's an honor to be here today.
I thought I would start--
you just heard who I am.
I thought I'd start by
asking a little bit about you
guys and what brought
you to the talk today.
So how many people here are
programmers in the room?
All right, a bunch
of programmers.
How many of you work
with big data sets?
How many have a biology
interest or background?
A few?
OK, great.
And how many of
you are interested
about your own microbiome,
like you came because you're
curious about yourself?
OK, good.
All right.
So there's a lot of reasons
to be here and learn something
at this Gladstone
Open Classroom.
I'm really pleased to be here.
As Paul mentioned
from my background,
I haven't been working
on the human microbiome
since undergrad or
a long time ago.
I was working in human genetics,
and in particular asking,
what's unique about
the human genome?
What makes us different from
chimpanzees and other animals?
And I made some really exciting
discoveries in that realm,
and I was working
really hard to use
comparative and
computational approaches
to decipher human DNA.
And there's a chunk of my
lab that still works on that,
and it's a great
interest of mine.
But about a decade
ago, a colleague who's
a microbiologist said to
me, sort of prodding me,
he said, you know, most of
the DNA in the human body
isn't encoded in
the human genome.
And I was like, yeah, whatever.
And he said, no,
really, it's not.
Most of the DNA
comes from microbes.
And I eventually believed him.
But then I thought,
well, they're
just kind of along for
the ride on our body.
This isn't really significant.
And I'm studying
the human DNA, which
is going to explain
who we are and why
we're different from each
other and why we get diseases.
But slowly, the more
I looked into it,
I realized that the
facts really support
the idea that the human
microbiome not only is
a large contribution to
our biological makeup,
but that it's not just
a passive contribution,
that the microbial cells in our
bodies, which are bacterial,
they're microbial
eukaryotes like yeasts.
They're archaea, which are a
sort of underappreciated part
of the microbial tree of life.
And they're also viruses
that don't have cells at all,
but are just
molecules in our body.
All of those organisms
together are not just
along for the ride.
They're interacting
with our cells
and forming essentially
additional organs or parts
of organs in our body.
And the genes encoded in
their DNA are making proteins,
and they're making the majority
of the proteins in our body.
And since proteins
are the things that
are the basic building
blocks of life,
it would be completely
irresponsible to not
be looking at the
microbial DNA to try
to understand human biology.
Now, the first
bullet point there,
about cells
outnumbering by 10 to 1,
there was actually,
if anyone caught
it, an article just
this week saying
that that estimate might be
off by an order of magnitude.
And so maybe about
half the cells
are human and half
microbial, not 10 to 1.
But either way,
there's certainly
a lot of microbial cells
in our body-- trillions.
So more than the dollars
in the national debt
might be an example.
So that's a very big number.
And because they're not
all-- our cells in our body,
all the trillions of
cells that are human,
have the same DNA in
them, modulo cancer
and some occasional other
mutations that happen.
But the microbial cells
are all different types.
They're different
organisms, different species
from one another.
So they have a lot
of different genomes.
And that's why, regardless
of whether the cells are
approximately equal or 10 to
1, the genes, the pieces of DNA
that encode proteins, really
are primarily microbial.
regardless of the cell count.
So we have these
microbes in our bodies.
And so why was I so
oblivious to this
when I was trotting along
looking at the human DNA,
and why is this sort of a
hot topic all of a sudden
that we're seeing in the
"New Yorker" or other news
that we might read?
The microbes have been there.
They've been evolving
with us as a species.
They're on plants.
They're on other animals.
So why were we kind of
not so tuned into them?
Well, it seems a bit surprising,
because people have been aware
of microbes for
hundreds of years.
But until about 10
to 15 years ago,
it was impossible to study
most of the microbes,
because the classic
approach was to extract them
from their natural environment,
which in this case is our body,
and try to grow them in
these dishes in the lab
and try to figure out what
they are and what they do.
But the vast
majority of microbes
that live in the human body, and
in fact, in most environments,
can't survive in
the lab environment,
because the conditions
aren't right,
and because they
can't survive alone.
This approach takes
one type of microbe
and tries to grow
it in isolation,
and these communities
are made up
of different types of
microbes that are all
interacting with each other.
So trying to grow them in
this way just doesn't work.
So they're not amenable
to this direct study
by microbiological techniques.
But the advent of
two technologies
that are the absolute sort
of basis for all the work
that we do in my
lab have enabled
us to get over
this hurdle, which
is that we can footprint
or measure what's
there by looking at their DNA.
And so that is possible because
of next-generation or low-cost
high-throughput sequencing
that you can extract DNA
from the community
without the cells needing
to be able to grow in the lab.
You can just directly assay it.
So if I wanted to study your
microbiome here in the room
today, I could pass
around a test tube
and have you spit
in the tube if I
wanted to study the microbes in
your saliva or in your mouth.
I could collect a stool sample
to study your gut microbiome,
or I could actually go in
and take some of your skin
or take a biopsy.
Some of those are more
invasive, but as you can see,
it's pretty easy to just extract
some bodily fluid or tissue,
and then I can extract
DNA, sequence it.
And then the other
technology that's essential
for this work is
high-performance computing,
which should be no surprise
to a Google audience.
But the data sets from
a single saliva sample
could be up to a few terabytes.
And if I want to
analyze a bunch of these
and compare them to each
other and do modeling,
I need high-performance
computing.
So because of low-cost
high-throughput sequencing
and advances in
computing, it's become
possible now to study microbial
communities and the human body,
and also in natural
environments.
And the basic
questions that in any
of these samples that one
wants to ask are, who's there?
So what types of
microbes are there?
And we call this a
taxonomic profile,
or what-- and also, and
perhaps more importantly,
what are they doing?
So what genes, what proteins
are encoded in their genome,
and what does that
say about how they
might be interacting
with our human cells
or affecting our health?
So an example would be that
microbes in your microbiome
might encode an enzyme
that would metabolize
a drug that you take.
So we are probably all aware
of the idea of personalized
or precision medicine.
This has been in the
news a lot, and the idea
is that when you go into the
doctor's office and a drug
is prescribed, that the
type of drug or the dose
might depend on your
own genetic makeup,
that different people
respond differently or need
different doses or have
different adverse reactions
that other people don't have.
Well, your microbiome is
also involved intricately
in metabolism of a
drug, and so knowing
that you had a
microbe that was going
inactivate a
particular drug would
be really helpful information.
It would also be helpful to know
if your microbiome was going
to extract more energy or
less energy from your food
than somebody else's, or
make your gut membrane more
permeable or cause more
inflammation or less
inflammation, or just be a
signature for where you grew up
or where you came from,
or how you were raised,
or how many times you've
ever taken antibiotics.
Does it encode
antibiotic-resistant genes?
So there are a lot of
really interesting questions
we can ask if we know who's
there and what they're doing.
So I should have said
at the beginning, also,
I'm happy to take
questions during the talk.
If anything's not clear,
please interrupt me.
I don't want this to be formal.
And I will also take
questions at the end.
So how do we do this, since
there are some data scientists
and programmers in the room.
I won't go into a lot
of technical detail,
but I wanted to give you
some of the detail of what
this computation looks like.
So the data set, as I said, can
be a huge file or a database--
terabytes of data.
So what is it?
These are DNA or RNA or
proteins, different kinds
of biomolecules.
But let's just take
DNA as an example.
And we read sequences,
little fragments
from the genomes of
all the organisms
that are in the sample.
And those fragments
would be typically
on the order of 100 base
pairs or a couple hundred base
pairs-- base pairs being
A's, C's, T's, and G's
that encode genetic information.
So one sample, like
your saliva sample
that I would collect
in a test tube,
we might obtain on the
order of, say, 50 million
of these 100-letter-long
sequences from it.
So that's the file or the
database that I would create,
and that's what I'm calling
the metagenome here.
These little lines
represent the sequences.
And there's not 50
million lines there,
but it's just a representation.
So if I want to
know what's there
and what functions are encoded
or what genes those fragments
came from, the basic
thing that we do, and this
is sort of-- there are
many variants of it,
but the basic idea
is we compare that
to database of sequences
that we've seen before,
either directly to the
sequences or to a model, which
is a more sensitive
way of comparing
the sequences-- a model of
what certain gene families look
like.
So we can do a
probabilistic comparison
to the model or a
direct comparison.
And my lab didn't invent
sequence alignment
or what we call here
homology search-- so seeing
if a sequence looks
like it's similar enough
to say it's the same as
one of these sequences--
but we spend a lot of time
tuning those algorithms so they
work with these really big data
sets of little fragments that
come-- unlike other
types of genomic data,
they come from lots of different
organisms, many of which
we've never seen the
genome of before.
So there won't be any perfect
matches in the database.
So since a lot of people here
probably think about search,
that's kind of the challenge.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Just a quick
question on that.
When you--
KATHERINE POLLARD: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] in
which ones, for example.
KATHERINE POLLARD: Yeah, so for
the protein sequence databases,
there is at the NCBI a
non-redundant sequence
database that has
everything that's
ever been publicly deposited,
and with direct exact copies
deleted.
So non-redundant means
one copy of each.
There's also genomes
that we can download,
so we can align not to gene
sequences but to whole genomes.
So we have all the genomes.
There's about
30,000 genomes that
have been sequenced so far,
most of which are microbial.
Those are available
through NCBI.
A slightly curated
version of them
is available through
a database called
PATRIC that's hosted in the UK.
There's data
resources in the US,
mostly through
NCBI, and in Europe
mostly through the European
Bioinformatics Institute
or EBI.
They have mostly the
same data in them.
There are some smaller
sort of niche databases.
And in terms of
annotation, there's
a bunch of functional
annotations
that get laid on top
of these sequences,
such as the pathways
that they're in.
KEG is an example of a database,
the Kyoto Encyclopedia.
We also have a
lot of annotations
that would be layered
on top of the sequences.
So after we find a
match, we can see what's
known about that sequence.
Does that answer?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Just one quick follow-up.
KATHERINE POLLARD: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is that a problem
that there's so many
databases, and is there any
effort to unify [INAUDIBLE]?
KATHERINE POLLARD: Yeah,
it can be a problem,
because each one is quite large.
And if you want to
host this locally,
it can be kind of an
unbearable amount of data.
There are differences
in results if you use
one database versus another.
We had a paper this
past year showing
that the-- we studied
some ocean data
and showed that you
come to completely
different conclusions
about photosynthesis,
and it's like at
different times of day,
at different times
of year, based
on which gene database you use.
So it is a problem.
There is a group called the
Genomic Standards Consortium
that's attempting to establish
some standards in this field.
And actually the White House
is really interested in this,
so I made several visits to the
White House in the past year
to talk about data
standards for this field,
because it's a little
bit Wild West right now.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] GA for GH?
KATHERINE POLLARD: The what?
AUDIENCE: The GA for
GH, Google Alliance
for Genomics and Health.
KATHERINE POLLARD: No, actually.
So this is specific
to microbiome.
It may be kind of
connected with that,
but that would be a
broader initiative
that would cover other types of
data, not just microbiome data.
This was specifically
around the microbiome,
and it was called the
Unified Microbiome Project.
But a lot of them
have the same people,
and there's just overlapping
people in discussions.
So yeah, the data curation
is a really important aspect.
And we've spent
some time-- I think
we're one of the
only labs that's
stopped to ask if it actually
matters which database you use,
or exactly what
runtime parameters you
use for these blasts search.
So if you change your cutoffs or
your preprocessing of the data,
we've seen that can
have a huge effect
on the biological conclusions.
And that's been, I think,
underappreciated in the field.
So we've been kind
of a bit curmudgeony,
but spending a lot of
time sort of figuring out
how these choices in
the analysis pipelines
affect the conclusions
that someone makes.
And we can do that with either
gold-standard data sets, where
we're pretty sure
we know the answer,
or we also do a
lot of simulations.
So we take all the genomes
that are out there,
we create metagenomic
communities,
we fragment them up and simulate
the sequencing experiment
on the computer, and then
since we made the community,
we know the answer and we
can see in which situations
you make false conclusions
or overestimate things.
So it's not perfect, because it
doesn't capture all the noise
in real life, but
it's nice because we
can see where things
break down by trying
a lot of different scenarios.
So the basic output is a
count of the number of reads
that hits a taxonomic group,
like a particular type
of bacteria or a function,
a protein family.
And part of this sort of
rigorous evaluation we've done
has shown that you have to
normalize in a variety of ways.
So a long gene, just
by chance you'll
get more sequences from it.
But it doesn't mean there's
more copies of the gene.
It just means it's longer.
That's a really simple
example, but there
is a lot of other biases
in these experiments
that need to be accounted for,
for accurate quantification.
Accurate quantification
is important
if you want to compare
across samples.
Maybe within a sample
it's not so important,
but if I want to
compare my microbiome
to a bunch of other
people's, or do a big meta
analysis of publicly
available data,
I need these measurements
to be meaningful,
biologically meaningful and
comparable across samples.
And that's a huge problem
in the field right now.
And we have to point that out.
So one of the more often
touted associations
between the microbiome
and human biology
is a reported association
with human body mass index.
So an argument was made here
under where it says Ley,
and you see the purple bars.
That was an early study with
19 people in it, 12 of which
were obese, seven
lean, and there
was more of a particular
phylum of bacteria
called firmicutes, which
is the x-axis, proportion
of the sequencing library
that was firmicutes.
There was more in
the obese people,
so it was concluded that the
microbiome was associated
with obesity, and
perhaps even playing
a causal role in
obesity, or mediating
effects that would on obesity.
And then in difference, we did
a meta analysis about two years
ago now where we looked
across different data sets
that either were designed
to look at obesity
or weren't, they were just
random samples of people,
but they had lean and obese
individuals in the study.
And what we found
was if you don't
do a careful job normalizing
the data, and even if you do,
there's some unaccounted
variability that
actually results in two things.
The first one is that you don't
see a consistent association
with obesity.
In these data sets
there actually
isn't more firmicutes in
the obese people in general,
especially as the
study sizes get larger,
like they are on the other side,
in the pink and green bars.
But more upsetting to me
was that this biomarker
for obesity, that
a lot of firmicutes
varied more between
the studies that it
did between the lean
and obese in each study.
And so something-- and
this isn't a very sort
of fine resolution measurement.
Firmicutes are one of the
two most prevalent phyla
of bacteria, phylum being
the highest taxonomic level.
So a lot of the
sequencing-- there
were millions and
millions of sequencing
reads supporting these estimates
of the amount of firmicutes,
and yet they still got in some
studies like 20% firmicutes
on average across
lots of people,
and in other studies 80%.
So there are a number
of technical reasons
why that might be.
There could be also
biological reasons,
like these are different
study populations, adults
living in different
parts of the world.
Some of them are college
students, maybe different diets
or lifestyles.
So some of this could be
real biological differences
between the populations,
and some of it I'm sure
is also technical differences
in how they did the experiment.
So there is a bunch
of issues that I'm not
going to go into
in detail, but just
something that might be
interesting for you to know
is when you see a headline, the
microbiome causes this or is
associated with that, there is
I think in the field right now
a lot of bias still,
and a lot of-- I'm
afraid that a lot
of those results
aren't going to replicate when
someone does another study,
that people are
sort of overfitting
data in a particular
study or that
has a particular bias in how
the measurements were made.
And this isn't so shocking.
This is a new technology,
there's a lot of excitement,
and there's a lot of real
promise around it as well.
But with any new technology
that comes online,
I think it takes a little
while to figure out
what all the hitches are.
And I think we're
still figuring that
out with microbiome
experiments right now.
But I'm not totally pessimistic.
Our lab and a number of
other groups around the world
are working hard to
solve these problems.
So I think there is a lot of
promise for this approach.
But I also think
there's a lot of sort
of noisy and contradictory
data out there right now.
So luckily, yeah,
some of these problems
that we observe in the data
can be modeled and corrected
for in the analysis.
So we generate a little
bit of this kind of data
in my own lab,
but the main thing
we created our research
program around is data mining.
So a lot of people
deposit not only
genome sequences
for microbes, but
these metagenomic
experiments where
they've sampled people
with different traits
from different
parts of the world,
and also non-human primates or
other organisms' microbiomes.
And most of this data
is publicly available.
So the details don't
matter, but this is just
a list of a bunch of
the larger studies.
And this isn't all the
data that's out there.
We have at this point close
to 2 terabytes of data
on our lab server
that we've downloaded
from public resources.
But for these
particular comparisons,
we grab a certain
subset of the data sets.
And this can be on
the order of sort
of tens of terabytes of data.
And you can see that the
people who have been studied
are from a number of
different countries.
And excitingly, and I'll show
some of this later in the talk,
like any new sort of
field of biomedicine,
at first most of the
people who are studied
are North Americans and
Europeans, and maybe
someone from Japan or China.
But there have been a few
studies in individuals living
in nonindustrialized
countries that
are revealing some really big
differences in the microbiome
that I'll touch on.
So with all the caveats
of issues of data quality
and normalization in mind,
I want to nonetheless
share with you some of the
things that our field has
discovered about the microbiome.
Some of these are our work
in my lab and some of them
are work of other colleagues.
So what's come to light,
and perhaps some of you
know this already, that
one of the strongest
drivers of differences
between microbiomes
between different
people is what you eat.
So what we put into our
bodies is the energy source
also for our microbiome.
And so depending on diet,
we see large differences.
And these are pretty
massive differences,
like on the scale
of what I showed you
of those differences
between studies
in the amount of firmicutes.
Someone could have
20% and someone else
could have 80% of their
sequencing be from firmicutes.
And that can be flipped
within about 24 hours
by changing what you ate.
So it's not what you ate 50
years ago, for the most part,
but what you literally just ate.
So a friend and colleague
at UCSF, Peter Turnbow,
has done experiments
where he switches
people between different diets
and sees these rapid shifts.
Others have looked in
infants, and there's
some differences between
breastfeeding and formula--
also between caesarean
and vaginal birth,
because you pick up--
the womb is sterile
and you get your initial
inoculate during birth.
That can affect you
for several years,
and perhaps have long-term
effects on your health.
Switching between a
vegan and a meat diet
has a huge effect on the
composition of your gut
microbiome.
And those effects are
seen quickly, within a day
or so of shifting, and
can be shifted back
by just changing the diet back.
And despite the sort
of inconsistent results
we see when we just
sample people and ask--
we see no association
if we just sample them
and ask if their microbiome is
associated with their body mass
index, so how obese they are.
Yet there is some
relationship, because you
can take the microbiome
of an obese person,
or an obese mouse that
was created genetically,
in the case of the
mouse, or by diet,
you can transfer fecal
matter to a mouse that
doesn't have a microbiome
that's been raised germ-free,
and you can induce
some of the aspects,
like some weight gain and
some metabolic differences.
So these shifts
in the microbiome
that I'm describing
in response to diet
can have physiological
effects and could
in theory effect
something like obesity,
even though we don't see a
simple signature for that when
we look at the whole data set.
So there may still
be-- I'm not proposing
that there's no
relationship with obesity,
because in an experimental
system we can control it.
But out in the
population, there's
too many other things
going on to see
that kind of association.
The microbiome isn't
just responding
to our diet for its
own sake, but it's also
producing a lot of
molecules from our diet
to help us to harvest
energy, synthesize vitamins.
So a bunch of things that
happen during digestion,
or as I mentioned earlier
in metabolizing a drug,
a bunch of those things cannot
happen without the microbiome.
So we're working on
a study right now
where a very toxic metabolite
that causes liver damage,
it can be eliminated
by just changing
the microbiome, essentially.
So there are a lot of
not just their genes,
but the byproducts
of those genes,
of the pathways that
those genes encode--
a lot of the
molecules in our body
that cause health
or disease are being
produced by the microbiome,
sometimes multiple microbes.
So to make that end
product, that, say,
anti-inflammatory might take
several different microbes
contributing, and maybe
some human genes too.
So it can be quite
complicated-- not as
easy as remove this
one microbe or add
this other one, in many cases.
And the gut microbiome,
which is the main source
that-- we have microbes
all over our body,
on our skin, in our ears, in
our noses, and pretty much even
parts of our body we thought
were sterile previously,
like the heart.
But the biggest chunk of
the microbes in our body
is in our gut.
By weight, most of us
have about six pounds
of microbes that
are in our body,
and like four pounds or so of
that is the gut microbiome.
But it's not only
important for digestion.
The gut microbiome
is also communicating
with your immune system,
hormones, and in some work
I find really fascinating,
through the vagus nerve, which
is how our brain controls
how our gut works,
and communication between
our gut and our brain.
Through the vagus
nerve, the microbiome
can communicate with our brain.
And that communication
is associated
with things like
mood, depression,
and certain behaviors,
and perhaps, there's
some new evidence, also autism.
So the gut microbiome
isn't just about the gut.
It's also affecting a lot of
other systems in our body.
And so not surprisingly,
there is every week
a paper coming out now
showing that the microbiome's
associated with a
different disease.
As I mentioned, I'm
fearful that some of those
may not replicate.
But nonetheless,
there are a number
of associations that have been
observed in large data sets
and have replicated.
Associating the
microbiome-- so saying, OK,
sick people tend to have
these types of microbes
or these types of
microbial genes,
is interesting, but it doesn't
really get at cause and effect.
So one of the big
pushes in my lab right
now is to ask why
the microbiome's
different in disease.
Was that a response
to the disease state?
Or was it actually
playing a causal role?
And to do that, we have
to do longitudinal studies
and look at people over time,
or do studies in the lab,
for example, with mice or
other models of disease,
and ask whether the
microbiome changes first
and then you start
seeing the disease,
or if it's the other way around.
And can you cause
the disease just
by changing the microbiome,
or alleviate it?
And the same thing
with metabolism
of a drug or any other trait
that you might want to look at.
The promise here,
which I think is
really interesting
and really amazing,
is that because the microbiome
can change so easily--
I mentioned going from
a meat to a vegan diet
can change the microbiome
within 24 hours--
because it's so
easily manipulated,
it could be a much
better therapeutic target
than trying to target a human
genetic cause of disease.
So gene therapy has
had some success,
and perhaps will have
more in the coming
years with genome
editing techniques
that have recently
been developed,
but it would still be pretty
challenging to go in and edit
someone's human genome to
fix a genetic disposition
to a disease.
But if you could just take a
particular yogurt or probiotic
or change your diet and have an
effect on the microbiome that
would change your
disease risk or alleviate
a bad response to a drug, that's
something that can much more
easily be manipulated.
That's not very invasive.
So there's a lot of promise.
And also, just traditional
drug development,
like taking a
protein and have it
change how some protein
in the human body works,
we can also do that to
target microbial proteins.
So without even
changing the community,
we could also drug the
microbiome, essentially.
So I think there's
a lot of potential.
But what I want to talk about
for the next part of the talk
is a different idea, which is
that the microbiome isn't just
causing disease, but is
actually protecting us
from disease-- that
there's a lot of components
of the microbiome
that are healthy,
and that disease might be
caused just by losing microbes,
not by gaining bad ones,
but losing good ones.
So there's a hypothesis that's
been around for a long time.
I didn't come up with this,
but I'm very interested in it.
And the idea is that we
evolved over millions
of years with a lot more
microbes than most of us
have in our bodies now, because
modern life has eliminated
a huge component
of the microbiome.
So it's like removing an organ
from our bodies, essentially.
And we're all living
still, but there
are a number of diseases
that have sort of
rapidly and unexplictitly
risen in abundance
in industrialized countries.
And the strongest example
are the autoimmune diseases,
including things like
allergies and asthma,
inflammatory bowel
diseases, MS. So all
these autoinflammatory
diseases, it's hypothesized,
could be the result of
losing a big component
of our microbiome.
And I'm really interested
in this scientifically,
but also personally, because I
have two autoimmune diseases.
I'm a patient.
And there aren't really any
good explanations for my disease
or any-- there are sort of
things to help me get by,
but there aren't
really any cures.
And so I'm really also
as a patient excited
about this line of research.
So we've started to
do some work looking
at the microbiomes
of people who aren't
exposed to as much antibiotics
and such a clean lifestyle.
So this is a picture of students
who went to South Africa,
and we actually piggybacked
on a project that
was there to study the human
genetics of KhoeSan hunter
gatherers.
So these are people living in
South Africa in a lifestyle
like our ancestors had thousands
and thousands of years ago.
They don't have routine access
to medical or dental care.
They eat a really
different diet than someone
in an industrialized
country, they
don't brush their
teeth, et cetera.
So this team from
Stanford, friends of mine,
were-- Carlos Bustamante's
lab and others were going over
to study the human
genetics of these people,
and the student who was
sort of shared with my group
came to lab meeting and
said, it really sucks,
we have all this bacterial
contamination in our samples,
and some of them it's like
85% of our DNA isn't human,
it's bacterial.
And I said, don't
throw that away.
I want to look at it.
So a postdoc from my lab got
busy with the contamination.
And what we found was that
some of the most abundant--
not surprisingly, but
we found that some
of the most abundant organisms
in these KhoeSan people,
and I'm sorry the data
isn't really easy to see,
but the result is
stated in words there.
We found some of those
most abundant organisms
in these hunter-gatherers
are rare or completely absent
from people in the study I
label HMP as Human Microbiome
Project.
That was hundreds of individuals
living in the United States.
So this was our initial foray.
And then as I noted
earlier, there
have been some other
people, friends,
who've studied people in
other parts of Africa.
And there's been a
great study in Peru
of two different groups,
one of hunter-gatherers
like these KhoeSan people, and
another of agriculturalists,
neither living a very
modern lifestyle,
but different lifestyles
from each other.
And they've generated
a ton of data.
And at this point
there's over 3,000
of these shotgun
metagenomic experiments
from people from different
parts of the world.
The majority are from China,
North America and Europe,
but we're now getting some data
from other parts of the world.
And what my lab has done
is a big meta analysis,
so we downloaded or
mined all this data
and then analyzed
it together, not
the way it was
necessarily analyzed
in the original
studies, but in bulk
to deal with a lot of
the confounding issues
that I talked about
earlier, and then
asked how the microbes look.
Are they the same
in different people,
or do they look different
depending on where in the world
you are from?
And we did this for each
of every common microbiome
constituent.
So here's one example.
This is eubacterium rectale.
It's common in the
human microbiome.
And there's a map there
showing the sampling locations
with the little
Google dots on it.
And there's a phylogenetic
tree that I just
overlaid on the map.
The exact position on
the map doesn't matter.
This is just a visual
representation.
But the colors of
the dots represent
where the person came from
whose microbiome was sampled,
and the tree is showing
how related they are.
So if things are close
together in the tree,
then those two
people's microbiomes
were really similar, and not
overall, but specifically
for this species of bacteria.
So for this species, we
see a lot of structure.
For example, the
yellow dots over there,
which are all
Chinese individuals,
form their own
clade in the tree.
So everyone in China has
a eubacterium rectale
that's more similar to
other people in China
than to anybody
in another place.
The individuals from
the southern hemisphere
are pretty different
from everybody else.
And the North American
and European clades
are mixed together.
So there's a lot of exchange
of the different strains
between Europeans
and North Americans.
There's sort of different
groups there, but if you look,
they're kind of a mix
of people from Europe
and people from North America.
So that's what this
microbe looks like.
But then we go to a
different species,
this is bacteroides
uniformis, and it
wasn't found at
all in the people
in the southern hemisphere.
So the African or
the South Americans,
it was wasn't present as far
as we could tell in them.
But if you were from North
America, Europe, or China,
you just had kind
of a random strain.
So these strains were all pretty
closely related-- not that
closely related, but they didn't
form any geographic-- there was
no geographic pattern at all.
This thing gets around,
this particular species,
and a new strain
arises in it, at least
in the northern hemisphere
is spreading all around
to different peoples.
So if you're living
here in California,
your strain could
look the most--
the person in the world with
the most similar strain to you
could be in China.
But that isn't the case
for this other microbe.
That would be highly unlikely
that someone in China
would have the same
rectale as you.
So we thought this was
really interesting,
that there was a geographic
signal for some microbes
and not for others.
And we're also now looking
at non-human primates.
So sort of back to my
original research program
of humans versus
chimps, we're looking
in chimps and gorillas and
baboons to see how they fit in.
And so far it looks
like they have
pretty different
microbiomes than we do,
and that the people in the
non-industrialized countries
look more like than
non-human primates.
So that's probably like
our ancestral microbiome.
And then those of us in the
more industrialized countries
have a divergent
microbiome that's
changed from an ancestral state.
So that's our
hypothesis right now,
and we're continuing
to work on that.
So just the last thing
I wanted to mention
is that our main focus
is the human body,
but microbes are the
major constituents of most
ecosystems.
And there is some
work in my lab that's
looking in natural
environments as well.
And even less is known about
the microbes that are there.
So actually, saying that 1% of
the microbes in the human body
have ever been studied by
traditional microbiological
techniques, it's less than that
if you go out and sample out
in the San Francisco
Bay or on the windshield
wipers of your car, or out
in the desert somewhere.
And yet the microbes are
playing really important roles
in ecosystem services,
in global warming,
and also they help to mediate
things like oil spills.
Some microbes can
eat toxic things
and totally help out with
these natural disasters.
There's microbes that
are still chewing away
at all the mercury that's
up in the Sierra Nevada
from mining during the gold
rush and slowly degrading
a lot of the mercury
and other heavy metal
toxins that are up there.
So it would be helpful from
an ecological perspective
to also know who is there
and what they're doing.
So these same tools
are being applied
to natural environments.
And just really briefly,
I wanted to show you,
I won't talk too much
about the modeling,
but the challenge--
the human body
is complicated enough to sample.
Something like the
world's oceans is massive.
Microbes are tiny.
The oceans are massive.
If there's trillions of
microbes in each of our bodies,
imagine how many are
in the world's oceans.
So we have sort of sparse
sampling of what's out there.
And one of the approaches
my lab has used
is to try to build
models to predict
what's going on in places
where we haven't sampled yet.
So a couple years
ago we had a paper
where we used this technique
to reconstruct an essentially
extinct ecosystem called
tall grass prairie, which
used to cover the Midwestern
United States before
so many people were there, and
before agriculture, monoculture
basically destroyed
this ecosystem.
And we did that by sampling in
graveyards where the tall grass
prairie hadn't been disturbed,
and in some nature preserves,
the only places where the
tall grass prairie still
exists, built a model for
which kind of microbes
you find in which
kinds of soil, and then
used what we think that the
climate and other properties
of the soil were
before agriculture,
and predicted what microbes
you would find where.
And this is just a heat map
that's showing the diversity.
So the warmer colors would be
like a more diverse community
of microbes would be found in
certain parts of the Midwest
compared to others.
So we did this modeling.
We're also thinking forward.
So if you can build
a model like this,
you can predict for soils
or air or the oceans what
the microbes will look like
in future climate scenarios.
So we've been doing
a lot of that.
And it looks like
as the Earth warms,
the microbes are
going to like it
and we're going to get
more diversity across most
of North America, Tibet, a
lot of the world's oceans.
So that's something
to keep in mind.
And one particular
health consequence
is that particular microbes
that have effects on humans,
such as fungal allergens in air,
may change as climate changes.
So this is a study where
we sampled on the doorsills
of people's houses.
It's sort of a great
passive collector for what's
in the environment, because
most people don't clean
on the top of their door sills.
And it was called the
1,000 Homes Project.
We had a bunch of collaborators.
But anyway, it was a
citizen science project.
People sampled
their own doorsill
and then sent the samples
in and we sequenced them.
And a lot of things were
discovered in that data,
but this analysis focused
on fungal allergens.
So you can see if
there is DNA from fungi
that are known allergens.
And so we mapped where
the allergens were
found across the United States.
And then in these pictures,
what we did was we
plugged in values for
future climate scenarios.
And what this is
showing is the change
in the amount of microbes.
So for this particular-- I'm
just showing a few examples,
but for this epicoccum
nigrum, which
is a pretty wicked
pathogen and can
kill immunocompromised
people, we
see in red-- red would be an
increase in the amount of it.
So California is going to get
a lot more nigrum in the future
than it has now, as
well as the South.
Other places might get
less, as shown in blue.
And then this other
species, alternaria,
is mostly decreasing,
but it looks
like Florida is going to
get pretty hit by this one.
So we can make those kind
of predictions as well.
So to wrap up, getting
back to the human health
angle and our own biology,
just a couple summary
points about what the
field has learned so far.
I feel like it's
just very early days
for this field of research.
There are a lot of
technical problems
we're still trying to overcome.
But we've already observed that
we can't explain human biology
completely by just looking
at our own human DNA
and that our individual
microbial communities are
certainly playing a
complex role in our health
and our normal day-to-day life.
And what makes us human
or makes us who we are
isn't just our own
DNA, but also the DNA
of the particular microbes
we are carrying around
at any given time.
This is not fixed.
We're not stuck with
it for our whole life.
It's manipulatable.
And so it's likely that
health care in the future
will actually be leveraging this
to diagnose you and potentially
treat you as an alternative to
more invasive things like drugs
or surgery.
So that's where we're
looking towards the future.
I think there's
a lot of promise,
but I also think there's
a lot of challenges.
So I'll be really
excited for collaboration
with anyone here who has ideas
about how to work on the field,
and I'm very happy to
take any questions.
So thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Is there a certain aspect of
the data that is less confounded
or has less technical
problems in current days?
Like if I would go
read papers now,
what would I believe
more than not?
KATHERINE POLLARD:
That's a great question.
So let's see if I can't
explain what I think
one of the biggest problems is.
It's pretty technical,
but let me give it a shot.
So the common thing
that someone does,
let's say to say how
much of bacteroides
uniformis do you have,
to quantify that,
is that they look
at the 50 million
sequencing reads and see
how many of those align
to uniformis, maybe you
normalize that count
a little bit, and then divide
by the total sequencing library.
So it's the proportion
of your sample
that came from that bacterium.
And unfortunately, what
we really care about
is something about
the community,
like what proportion of the
cells were of that type.
And it turns out the
proportion of the sequencing
reads isn't a very good estimate
of the proportion of the cells.
And I'll try to explain a
couple of the reasons why.
One is that different
organisms will have
genomes of different sizes.
So something with a really
big genome, like a yeast,
like a fungal
allergen, could take up
a whole bunch of your
sequencing library,
but there might only
be a few cells there.
The human DNA is in there.
So I mentioned that
the student thought
the bacteria was a contaminant
of his human genetic study.
We think of the human
DNA as a contaminant
of the microbial study.
And it can be up to
half of the sample.
So if half your library
just went to human,
that can kind of
skew the ratios.
So as the genome sizes of the
organisms change, the amount
of contamination from human
or from the lab process--
unfortunately, one
of the kits that's
used for extracting
the DNA biases
the ratios of different
types of organisms.
So what can you trust?
I would say if
you see in a paper
that something measured the
actual cellular abundance
or cellular relative
abundance of an organism,
I would believe
that as something
really quantitative
and comparable,
but not the sort of proportion
of the sequencing reads.
And so that's not sort of
like a field of inquiry
that's reliable, but a
statistic that I think
is really reliable.
You would have to
dig down a little bit
to find that, obviously.
But I wish I could say that,
say, high level things were
easier to estimate, like the
amount of a particular phylum--
you might not get a
specific species right,
but you might get the phylum.
You know a higher
taxonomic resolution.
I actually don't
think that's the case.
And I actually think
studies that drill down
on one specific thing and
quantify it very carefully
probably do better than the
ones that are sort of trying
to get everything right.
I also think that
right now, studies
that do this experiment
of sequencing
just all the random sequences
are-- still a lot of them
are problematic.
But some people are going in
and targeting specific things
and sequencing those.
In general, that's
probably more reliable,
like more targeted studies.
I think that the unbiased
approach has a lot of promise,
but we're not quite there yet on
a lot of the analytical tools.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Oh, definitely.
KATHERINE POLLARD:
Yeah, OK, great.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: You were just
talking about a lack
of analytical tools.
KATHERINE POLLARD: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious to know
where are the biggest gaps,
and what kinds of
technologies are
you guys currently developing
or would like to develop?
KATHERINE POLLARD:
Yeah, great question.
So we're developing a lot of
tools for these normalizations
that I mentioned, adjusting
for the size of the genome,
so trying to estimate
and then adjust
for the size of the
genomes in the sample
and the amount of contamination
and other sorts of biases.
Those are kind of
under the hood.
And they require someone to be
like a command line programmer
to run them.
But actually what I wanted to
show you was something that I
thought might be interesting.
We're basically trying
to make this research
accessible to other people,
because my lab can't think
of all the interesting
questions to ask,
or have time to ask all
of them of the data.
So we've downloaded
every microbiome study
that's ever been done.
There's over 3,000 now.
And we've, we think as
accurately as currently can,
quantified the amount
of every protein family
and every microbe in them.
And then we've compared them
across these 3,000 samples,
some of which have
diseases or are
from different
parts of the world,
or different aged individuals
or males versus females.
We've computed all that
as like a pre-compute,
and then we've built this tool
so people can search the data
and just pull out the answers.
And so, let's see.
It's a search tool.
You can search right
here by a gene,
and we're adding something that
would be more like a Google
search, where you search by a
word, like obesity or enzyme,
or ABC transporter.
So we're still working.
That will be out in
another month or two,
expanding the
search aspect of it.
And then here, I think if
I'm online I could show you,
these are just jobs
that have run recently.
So I can pull up a
job and show you--
this is in development right
now, so it's not beautiful.
But someone searched
a gene sequence,
and then these are things
that we think it might be.
So these are like possible
annotations of it.
This is a quantification
of how common
it is in the human microbiome.
So people-- some people
have no copies of this
in their microbiome,
some of the samples,
and the sample with
the most of this gene
had 2.3 copies per organism
in their microbiome.
So they had organisms that had
multiple copies-- on average
had more than two
copies of this gene.
So people vary a lot.
These are some of
the taxa that have
the gene, some of the
bacteria that are carrying it.
And then you can
look at associations
with different traits.
So let's see if I can find one.
This is statistically
significant--
what country you're from.
So I can click on it.
And it looks like
this gene is more
common in the
microbiomes of people
from North America
compared to Europe or Asia.
So we've precomputed
all of these,
and these can just be
queried by somebody.
So that's one of the tools
that we're working on,
as well as under-the-hood
tools for making
sure the numbers that go
into these tests are accurate
qualifications.
Well, I'm happy to
stick around if anybody
wants to shout afterwards.
Thank you so much
for the opportunity.
[APPLAUSE]